all wide open and hit it Chris Paul with
his first three of the game in just a
sixth point
I like the patience of Booker because we
know the type of game he's having he
could have forced the action and look
for himself selfishly he took the track
Irving into the paint projected by
Durant
save it done
waiting right with eight to shoot back
to KD with six Durant driving on
Hardaway pull-up jumper Durant got it
Phoenix has a two-point lead 35 for
Durant this is just this is Kevin not
his best takes you off the dribble gives
you the fake and then create the space
and then his size I'm going to shoot up
over the top of excellent defense